-Today, Senate Democrats cleared
a major procedural hurdle
on their way
to passing their urgent
and desperately needed
Covid relief bill
with a tie breaking vote from
Vice President Kamala Harris.
But the victory comes
after moderate senators
demanded the Democrats limit the
eligibility for direct payments.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
Donald Trump was bad
at pretty much everything
when it came to politics.
He lost the popular vote twice,
lost the House
in 2018,
in the Senate this year,
got impeached twice
and never cracked
50 percent job approval once.
He fell ass backward
into the job
the way your burnout cousin fell
ass backwards into that job
dog sitting for a rich old lady
who was so senile
she started thinking
he was her dead husband.
So she put him in her will.
And then, like after only a week
of working for her,
she died
and he inherited a fortune,
and now he just
drives around town
in the back
of a Rolls-Royce, screaming,
asking pedestrians
if they have any Gray Poupon.
But one thing Trump was good at
was taking credit mostly
for things he had
nothing to do with.
He took credit
for a Veterans Choice program
that was signed
by President Obama in 2014,
not just once or twice.
He did it over 150 times.
And at some point,
you just have to tip your hat
at his commitment to lying.
I've never been that committed
to anything in my life.
I don't think I even did
150 shows at "SNL."
I mean, I was there for well
over 150 shows,
but it wasn't in all of them.
For some reason, they just
stopped using my John Kerry,
even though it's obviously
still relevant today
now that he's climate czar.
I've been emailing
Lauren suggesting that people
might want to see it again,
but it keeps getting
bounced back
with what I'm guessing
is an auto generated reply
that says,
"Why won't you take no
for an answer?"
Anyway, Trump took credit
for a lot of stuff,
so much so that when the first
round of Covid stimulus checks
went out last year, he insisted
that they put his name on them.
That's a government check,
but it looks like
it came from Trump's
personal checking account,
which I doubt
has any money in it,
unless it was a secret
Chinese bank account.
You guys remember that?
That tiny little detail
that quickly got overlooked
but would have otherwise been
a stunning bombshell twist
and an HBO prestige drama
starring Nicole Kidman
as a rich lady with a kid
at a fancy school.
My husband could never
have done this.
Ma'am, did you know about his
secret Chinese bank account?
I need to go for a walk on
the beach to think about this.
Give me my billowy shawl.
Trump's one of those rich guys
who's technically a billionaire,
but none of his money is liquid.
To put a quarter
in a parking meter,
you'd have to sell
shares in Eric.
Here's the new GameStop.
Father, no!
So Americans got a direct check
from Trump
with his name on it.
And you know what?
If that's how Republicans
are going to do things,
the Democrats should
absolutely do the same thing.
Send everyone a giant
game show check
that says, "From your best bud,
Joe Biden."
For years centrist Democrats
have had a history of coming up
with well intentioned
but super complicated,
hard to understand programs
instead of just giving
people things they need,
like money and health care.
Instead of saying,
here's your check,
they say good news,
we passed tax credits
for small businesses
that retrain coal miners
to become pet therapists.
But then Democrats seem
to learn their lesson.
They promised a lot of bold,
easy to understand programs
during the 2020 campaign
that would improve
lots of people's lives.
And when Joe Biden
went to Georgia in January
for the Senate runoffs,
he made this very simple
promise.
-By electing John
and the reverend,
you can make an immediate
difference in your own lives,
the lives of the people
all across this country,
because their election
will put an end
to the block in Washington
and that $2,000 stimulus check,
that money that will go
out the door immediately.
-That's straight talking Joe.
No bluster, no BS.
He's the dad who says
if you get straight A's,
he will take you to Dairy Queen.
And when the ink is still hot
on the report card,
your elbows deep
in your blizzard.
Finally, Democrats promise
something big
and straight forward
that will immediately materially
improve people's lives.
By the way, not only did
that promise help win both
Senate seats in Georgia,
the Democrats Covid bill
is incredibly popular.
76 percent of Americans,
including 60 percent
of Republicans, support it.
76 percent.
You know how hard it is
to get 76 percent
support for anything?
There isn't even
76 percent support
in my own family for my
Al Pacino impression.
I mean, the kids love
Uncle Al,
[as Pacino] but wifey
is not on board.
All Democrats have to do now
is have the fortitude
to stick together,
pass this thing
and get the money
into people's pockets ASAP.
So naturally, some moderate
Democrats are watering it down
for absolutely no reason at all.
-President Biden has conceded
to moderate Democrats
agreeing to narrow income limits
for the next round
of stimulus checks.
-Biden signing off
on an agreement
to tighten eligibility
for the stimulus checks
in the package,
now phasing out checks at
$80,000 for individuals,
down from $100,000
and $160,000 for couples,
down from $200,000.
-Around 12 million fewer
adults and five million
fewer kids
would get the stimulus payments
under the new Biden Senate
compromise,
according to
preliminary estimates.
A lot of those adults are voters
who will now get less
in direct cash assistance
from President Biden
than they did from Donald Trump.
-Democrats,
what's wrong with you?
Stop behaving like
your own opposition party.
Now is the time to go all in
while the GOP is distracted
by Potato Head's pronouns.
Do you really want to risk
being seen
as less generous
than Donald Trump,
the guy who infamously had
to shut down his charity
after he was accused of using it
as a personal checkbook to buy,
among other things, portraits of
himself and a football helmet
signed by Tim Tebow,
a guy who was so bad at football
he just retired
from a different sport.
What else did Trump buy
with the charity money?
A curling stone
signed by Johnny Manziel?
Seriously, Democrats,
who's asking for this?
Do you think there's
a group of people out there
who don't want a check.
Everyone wants a check.
That's why there are
eight million game shows,
including one
where you can win money
just by hailing a cab.
And true story, guys.
I hailed a cab last night
for the first time in a year.
It was the best.
Driver was blasting music.
I was watching "Taxi TV,"
saw a "30 Rock" clip,
emailed Tina Fey
to say how funny it was.
Windows down,
cold air blasted in.
When we arrived,
it just strolled right out
because in my head
it was an Uber.
Driver started screaming,
"Hey, hey, hey."
I figured he finally
recognized me with my mask on.
So I turn around,
I shoot him a thumbs up,
only to see
that he is very angry.
I apologetically get back
in the cab to pay
and stay to watch the weather
on "Taxi TV."
New York is back, baby.
I mean, it's not, but it's
getting closer and that's good.
Anyway, the point is,
this is insane.
It's political malpractice.
The bill does lots
of good stuff.
It's super popular
and it gives money to people
who need and deserve it.
Why would you make
fewer people eligible?
And by the way, taking checks
away from 17 million people
were reportedly only save
about $12 billion
out of a $1.9 trillion bill.
That's .6 percent.
Congrats, Moderates.
You really proved
your fiscal bona fides.
What's next? You can increase
the cost of a tasty cake
from a vending machine
by 25 cents.
You really think anyone
you're taking a check away from
is going to vote for you
because you're saving
$12 billion?
Well, honey,
we won't get a check,
but at least they brought
the cost of the bill
down from $1.9 trillion
to $1.888 trillion.
What are the main drivers
of this push
has been West Virginia Senator
Joe Manchin.
Manchin has been
critical of the direct payments
from the beginning,
despite the fact
that they're all
overwhelmingly popular in polls
among voters
of every political stripe.
In January, he told reporters,
"I don't ever remember
FDR recommending sending
a damn penny to a human being.
We gave 'em a job
and gave 'em a paycheck.
Yeah. Jesus criminy,
can't we start
some infrastructure program
to help people, get 'em back
on their feet?
Do we have to keep
sending checks out?"
Okay, first of all, why are you
talking like a character
in a Frank Capra film?
Jesus criminy?
You trying to save the old
building and loan.
Hey, Shoemaker.
Should I do my Jimmy Stewart?
Okay, well...
Okay, you're waving your arms.
It is very unclear
what you're trying to say.
Does this mean no?
Okay. Well, fine then.
Just stop moving around.
You'll give me vertigo.
[Laughter]
Also., do you remember
that FDR literally signed
the Social Security bill
into law?
Did you have a substitute
for that entire year
in history class?
Listen, I'm just
a field hockey coach,
so all I know
is there was a civil war
and then Nixon was laughing.
Now we're going to spend
the rest of the class
watching "Amadeus" on laserdisc.
[ Blows ]
Centrist Democrats
are also backing off
a $15 minimum wage,
which has the support of two
thirds of Americans in polls.
The minimum wage hike was
originally included in the bill,
but ruled ineligible
by the Senate parliamentarian
for reasons
that are too stupid to explain.
Basically, the gist is Democrats
have to use a process
called budget reconciliation
to pass the bill
with only 50 votes
because the Joe Manchins
of the world
won't just nuke the filibuster,
which they should.
The reconciliation process
doesn't allow
for so-called extraneous items,
and the person who gets to rule
What's extraneous
is the Senate parliamentarian,
who advised
last week that the minimum wage
was not allowed under the rules.
And hey, whatever you think
of the Senate parliamentarian,
whoever they are,
they were elected
and elections
have consequences.
What's that, Shoemaker.
You're waving your hands again.
Was the Senate parliamentarian
not elected?
Okay, it's just confusing
because you're using
the same waving motion
you used to tell me
I shouldn't do
my Jimmy Stewart impression.
Oh, help me out, Shoemaker,
you old so and so.
Well, if it ain't Jimmy Stewart.
Al Pacino?
"The Man Who
Shot Liberty Valance"
What serendipitous.
Anyway, the parliamentarian is
in fact an unelected bureaucrats
who basically just offer us
an advisory opinion.
Republicans fired
the parliamentarian in 2001
when they disagreed with
the parliamentarian's ruling,
and no one cared.
Democrats had the same power
to do the same thing now,
or they could just ignore and
overrule the parliamentarian.
That's what Senate Budget
Chairman
Bernie Sanders wants to do.
-The idea that we have
a parliamentarian
who was elected by nobody,
who was simply a Senate staffer
making a determination
that 30 million Americans
are not going to get a pay raise
is to me unacceptable.
So we're going to win this,
if not this week,
in the near future.
-They'll be separate legislation
if it's not included
in this legislation.
Is that what you're saying?
-I am saying that we are not
going to give up.
This is not going to be
the last vote on minimum wage.
Trust me on that.
We're sticking
with 15 bucks an hour,
and I believe
we're going to pass that.
-Yeah, people can't make
a living at $7.25
-You're right.
-They are in poverty
if they're working 40 hours
and only making $7.25.
That's way, way too low,
and it's been like that,
as we point out, since 2009.
-Wow, the minimum wage hike
is so popular
even Wolf Blitzer is on board.
Wolf Blitzer, the man never
reveals what he thinks.
His wedding vows
where it will be
very interesting to see
what happens going forward.
He's an enigma.
He doesn't even
make facial expressions.
The Wolf Blitzer emoji is just
a circle with nothing in it.
And it's true,
it is cruel and absurd,
to one,
tell people they can live
in 2021 on $7.25 hour,
and two,
let an unelected bureaucrat
no one's ever heard of decide
whether millions of Americans
get a raise.
And by the way, do you know
how hard it must be
for Bernie Sanders
to ignore someone
whose title is parliamentarian?
Bernie is the guy
who gets annoyed
when other people
don't follow the rules.
I bet he tells people
at the co-op to stop
squeezing the melons.
You get one squeeze
and that's it.
They all came in
on the same truck.
Just pick a melon
and be done with it.
We have a lot of people
here for melons.
And the current parliamentarian
has reportedly issued
other controversial rulings
and what can be passed
under special budgetary rules.
She ruled in 2017
that Republicans
could add provisions
to the Tax Cut and Jobs Act
to open the Arctic National
Wildlife Refuge
to Alaska oil drilling.
Why is oil drilling
in the Arctic allowed
but not a minimum wage hike?
Trying to make heads
or tails of archaic Senate rules
is like trying to
put together a shelf from IKEA.
I don't understand.
It's just an outline of a man
with an arrow pointing down
and a question mark
next to his head.
Above it,
it says klipphangare.
Wait, that's not a klipphangare.
This is a klipphangare.
Sorry, people on YouTube.
Sometimes we call back things
that aren't in the body
of "A Closer Look."
This is a whole show.
But don't tell me
how to say bubar.
[ Laughter ]
Democrats need to pull out
all the stops to pass this thing
because Republicans
are already making clear
they're going to pull out
all the stops to block it.
Wisconsin Senator Ron Johnson,
for example,
announced that he'd forced
the Senate clerks
to read the entire bill
aloud on the floor,
a formality which is
usually bypassed
as a stonewalling tactic.
-The first way
I'm going to resist
is I'm going to go down
and object
to the waiving
of the reading of the bill.
I will make them read their
600 to 700 page bill.
I'm going to lead the effort
to resistance
starting today, I think,
when they introduce
a substitute amendment.
I'm going to make them
read that thing.
Probably take about 10 hours.
-You really think that's going
to be a deterrent?
We've all been in quarantine
for a year.
I've done things that are
a lot less exciting
than listening to a bill
get read aloud for 10 hours.
One time I just laid down on
the floor with a bottle of gin
and tried to guess
how many layers of paint
there were on the ceiling.
Turns out the ceiling's wood.
I was just super drunk.
And my kids left me there.
Seriously, people desperately
need help immediately,
and you're playing
dumb procedural games
to stop them from getting it.
And just to give you an idea
of how dumb
Johnson's objections are,
yesterday he took the floor
of the Senate
with a ludicrous poster
to complain about
how much money was in the bill.
-If you stacked million dollar
bills on top of each other,
there would be -- they would
stack up to be
358 feet high.
So, how big would a stack
of a billion dollar bills be?
It'd be 67.86 miles.
So a stack of a billion dollars
would actually exceed
the atmosphere
and extend into outer space.
Well, how big would a stack
be of trillion dollar bills?
Well, it's a thousand times
that,
so it'd be 670,866 miles high.
We're talking about
$1.9 trillion,
which would stack up
to 135,732 miles high.
Madam President,
the distance to the moon
is 238,900 miles.
So that stack of $1.9 trillion
worth of one dollar bills
would be more than halfway
to the moon.
-Okay, Senator Snapple cap.
Save it for your sci-fi movie,
"Money Stairs to Moon Town."
Seriously, who cares?
Also, where did you get
that dumb poster made?
Did you actually force a staffer
to go to Kinko's?
So, what's this for?
A sixth grade math project?
No, it's for a congressman.
There's a sixth-grader
in Congress?
No,
He's an adult.
Oh. Is it Ron Johnson?
Yeah.
Democrats have lots
of bold agenda items
that could immediately help
lots of people
and fix
our broken political system,
from the urgent voting reforms
in the For the People Act
the House passed yesterday
to the Covid relief bill,
but they need
to stiffen their spines,
stop watering things down and
steamroll GOP obstructionists
because Republicans
are so crazy, they're...
-More than halfway to the moon.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
God's Love We Deliver cooks
and brings over
two million meals a year
to men, women and children
living with HIV, AIDS,
cancer
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the donate button.
Stay safe, wear a mask,
get vaccinated. We love you.